I was watching my few daily minutes of
MSNBC CNN and Fox News yesterday and I
happened to catch Ted Cruz on MSNBC in
one of the various shelter facilities
that are housing people that are
displaced by hurricane Harvey in Texas
and he imploded when Katie tore asked
him about his totally blatant hypocrisy
on hurricane relief funds and when I saw
this I knew I had to go back into our
archives because I was convinced I don't
remember we do so many stories sometimes
I forget did we do that story or did I
read that story a couple years ago but I
knew we had covered this before and we
did back on June 2nd of 2015 I reported
to you that despite having voted against
federal relief funding for victims of
Hurricane sandy which impacted people
mostly in the northeast of the United
States Texas Republican senator Ted Cruz
was demanding federal funding for
victims of Texas flooding that took
place a couple of years ago Cruz had
voted against relief funds for Hurricane
sandy he said it's all symptomatic of a
larger problem in Washington it's an
addiction to spending money we don't
have but then when it came to money for
his own constituents in Texas he said oh
listen it's the federal government
fulfilling its statutory obligations and
stepping in to respond to a natural
disaster well he's at it again
and Katie tore attempted to get him to
explain this obvious double standard in
some way other than well now it's my own
constituents and I want to get reelected
and he wound himself up into a pretzel a
we waited a soft pretzel at first he
tried not to answer the question at all
he sort of said oh that's political
sniping or something like that and Katie
tore didn't let him do it take a look
but a lot of people are pointing out
that you voted against aid for sandy
after that catastrophic catastrophic
storm up in the Northeast that package
back in 2012 and there they're pointing
at you and saying you're asking for
money now when you weren't willing to
help the people in the Northeast what do
you have to say that
yep well you know look there's time for
political sniping later I think our
focus needs to be it's not political
sniping Katie tours right it's a pretty
simple question of hey it appears you
can be counted on to push for money for
your own constituents but to get in the
way of money for non constituents when
they're all just victims of a natural
disaster in the United States so Katy
tour pushes him and he eventually gives
an answer even though it's an answer
that's been widely debunked for
something like five years running
funding right after that storm I covered
those people many of them just like
those in Houston lost absolutely
everything they owned well Katie Katie
of course that's right and and the
accurate thing to say is that I and a
number of others enthusiastically and
emphatically supported hurricane relief
for sandy hurricane relief and disaster
relief has been a vital federal for a
long long time and it should continue
the problem with that particular bill is
it became a fifty billion dollar bill
yet was filled with unrelated pork
two-thirds of that bill had nothing to
do with Sandy and and what I said then
and still believe now is is that it's
not right for politicians to exploit a
disaster and people are hurting to pay
for their own political wish-list
disaster relief needs to be focused on
the victims of disaster relief and I
supported that for sandy disaster relief
there and I would support that anywhere
there's a major disaster without getting
getting distracted by political
unnecessary pork spending oh that bill
had pork I see well let's evaluate that
assertion oh wait a second it's been
evaluated because Ted Cruz and other
Republicans have been using it for years
and it's just not true
PolitiFact looked at it they looked at
that 2012 superstorm sandy relief bill
and many Republicans use this talking
point some would say well 50 out of the
60 billion dollars in the bill what was
was pork Ted Cruz and others would say
two-thirds of the bill was pork others
said ninety percent of the bill is pork
the truth is its lies and it's not
actually clear exactly how much of the
bill was pork now don't get me wrong Pat
a lot of the bill was pork
of all of these bills is pork it was not
whatever percentage Ted Cruz thinks it
was it's true that there were some funds
in that bill as often is the case that
are for the future mitigation of natural
disasters so after a flood you would
have a bill that includes not only
Direct Relief money for the victims of
that flood but also some money to
strengthen infrastructure in case
there's another flood in the future
because rarely is the most recent
natural disaster the last natural
disaster but there's one other point I
want to make here part of the reason
that the 2012 superstorm sandy relief
bill had pork in it was because you had
red state Republicans like Ted Cruz who
didn't want to support it unless they
got some money for their pet projects so
Ted Cruz is exaggerating number one
number two an incredible hypocrite but
it's his own colleagues that were
demanding the pork and I just think that
even if you're operating from a purely
political perspective and not using your
heart not using empathy wouldn't it make
sense as a senator to support disaster
relief for sandy even though that's not
part of your constituency because you
realize that a natural disaster a
disaster could hit you one day and if
not a hurricane or tornado or a blizzard
or an earthquake and that's just how it
goes it makes sense if you're just a
sort of rational individual it makes
sense if you're just an empathetic
individual it makes sense if you're
gonna try to avoid being a hypocrite who
falls victim to these insane double
standards and to be super clear I'm not
for a second saying that because Ted
Cruz is a [ __ ]
we should punish the people of Texas now
and not give them aid no I think they
should get the aid the same way I
thought that superstorm sandy victims
should get the aid Ted Cruz is the
problem and his constituents are the
ones who need to realize that he's a
problem and maybe vote him out although
it's not particularly likely and
remember Ted Cruz was the guy who was
railing against New York values what
kind of values is he demonstrating here
not the hospitality that we associate
with the south of the United States I'll
say that for sure the video you just
watched was made possible by support
from you please go
to patreon.com slash david pakman show
you can make a pledge of as little as
one dollar per month and every dollar
helps to support the work that we're
doing particularly in light of the
YouTube ad boycott which has been really
bad